hey youtubers is charlie this is going
to be my game of thrones trailer Q&A you
guys had a bunch of awesome questions
just careful for everything that's
happened on the show so far one of the
cool things I noticed after i watched
the trailer a couple more times
yesterday is how much they're focusing
on the female characters in it i don't
know if this is indicative of what the
seasons going to be like or of HBO's
marketing team is just choosing to
highlight the females of the series more
I think it all plays into the absence of
Jon Snow's character like you see the
rise of Cersei during the King's Landing
plot where she's like I choose violence
and even though Jamie's a really big
character he still serves at her beck
and call just like Davos looks like he's
going to be answering at Santa's beck
and call questions here we go though
dave says Jaime and Brienne meet up then
he'll abandon the Lannister forces to go
fight with her for Sansa in the North
that would be super awesome but I'm
actually expecting this conflict to put
them at odds with each other Jamie's
probably going to have like a really big
choice to make because Brienne is trying
to save Santa Santa hates the Lannisters
Brianne has been serving the crown which
is the Lannisters effectively so I think
that Brian is definitely going to land
on Team Sansa as she is with the Tully's
in the scene here so if you are a big
fan of Jaime and Brienne together it
looks like they will have a reunion of
sorts before they're forced to make that
choice next question garm asks who is
the new red woman I don't remember
reading about her in the books as it's
been a while well she's actually
credited as Kinvara the High Priestess
High Priestess of role or so she's going
to be a really big person in the faith
of the red God the books don't really
explain how they organized their church
so it seems like this character is going
to be a much bigger badder version of
Melisandre so she's an example of
someone who would give Thoros of mere
his mission to go establish a foothold
for the Church of the red God in King's
Landing the funny thing about Thoreau
says he's like yeah I tried and I failed
so that's how he eventually made his way
to the Brotherhood without banners just
because the people in King's Landing
we're not having the red God at all
they're just like we don't we don't care
about this go away next question MC
plays asks do you think that Davos is
going to do the same thing he does in
the books and start rallying houses to
the north to fight for either John or
Sansa yeah I mean I definitely think
it's going to be a version of that in
the books he's doing it for stand as
though you have to remember the timeline
of the books is just a little bit
different so as Stannis is rallying his
army he sends Davos all over the place
to try and convert northern houses to
their cause so even though they are
doing book stuff
some stuff has been changed there is an
ax Stannis in the show's equation right
now next question Santa asks look at the
night's king on his horse is he carrying
the Horn of winter or just a white
Walker I see blade yeah there are a lot
of people that ask this is it's really
hard to see because the trailers just a
little bit fuzzy I think it's just a
regular blade but it is totally possible
that he could have the Horn of winter a
lot of people are just feeling like
that's going to be how he's going to
bring the wall down I would be really
surprised that they did it during this
season but at some point the White
Walkers will have to make their way
south of the wall so they can just start
smashing everyone but I think what's
gonna have to happen is is that everyone
will have their big battle in the north
they'll be fighting each other then
they'll recognize that the White Walkers
are a bigger threat the people who are
left in the rubble of this early fight
will have to find a way to come together
but it just feels way too early for that
to happen so I don't think we're gonna
see any horn of winter bringing the wall
down this season next question Chris
asks how on earth to those chains still
fit those dragons now well I mean they
probably have someone coaxing them as
they swap the chains out but i don't
think the dragons are gonna get so much
bigger than they were last year they'll
be bigger i guess if you really want a
nitpick then you just have to use TV
logic like you know at some point
someone came in and swapped the chains
out i think the point is related that
sometime during this season they will
become uncontrollable Tyrion as he
implies in the trailer thinks the
Dragons should probably roam free
whether he actually intends to release
them or not through his actions down
here below the pyramid they actually do
end up getting out whole bunch of dragon
questions Rose asks do you think that
the dragon that blows fire towards
Tyrion is going to become his dragon
like just how Drogo is bonded to
Daenerys no I don't think any of the
dragons are gonna bond to Tyrion like I
said I think he's just going to
accidentally release them there were a
whole bunch of questions because of the
way they cut this trailer it makes it
look like the dragon is breathing fire
on Tyrion I think that's a complete
misdirect I think whatever he does down
here that accidentally lets them out he
will narrowly escaped being turned into
a shish kebab I think of the series
wanted to tell you that he was a
Targaryen they'd be much more clear
about it like the way last season they
were laying in a bunch of liana stark
Rhaegar Targaryen stuff I think for the
most part Tyrion is what you see is what
you get I drink and I know things so I
don't I don't think there's any secret
backstory to Tyrion beyond what we see
right here next question drawing asks
need Lady Stoneheart right now do you
think she'll come back this season no
I'm not expecting her I expect all the
Reno revenge story line that she has in
the books to go to Sansa sophie Turner
was saying that stance is going to be a
badass [ __ ] this season it looks like
there's going to be some phrase so maybe
we'll get a version of the red wedding
like red wedding two point oh really the
big touchstones of the Riverland stuff I
feel like we're going to be Jamie and
Riverrun and Brienne quiet Isle next
question Boris asks what do you think
about the possibility of Syrio Forel
being Jack and Hegar i don't think that
serio is Jack and I think the serial
really did die I think that's the way
the show is playing it george RR martin
noise takes the stance that unless he
confirms dead that means a character is
still potentially alive but at the end
of last season when Aria was killing
Meryn Trant they had the flashback to
Syrio Forel the actor who played Syrio
Forel was tweeting funny things at the
actor who plays Meryn Trant just like
haha see you got yours finally got some
revenge for what happened to me so it
seems like the actor is pretty sure that
he's dead and not coming back on the TV
show but that doesn't guarantee that
he's dead in the books next question
ruben asks what do you think is going to
happen if the show chooses to keep Jon
Snow dead what if he's the new ozora hi
well I can't really speak to Azura high
there's a lot of people that want a
bunch of different characters there's
some crazy theories about that I don't
think it's as important as him actually
being resurrected I saw a lot of you
guys asking how long someone can be dead
and still be brought back by the red God
Lady Stoneheart was dead for three days
which makes it sound like a really funny
Jesus analogy dead for three episodes
then he is risen but the thing about the
TV show is is that the timelines get
kind of fuzzy during the season they're
not really clear on when days start when
days and they just kind of go to the
next episode they can totally keep him
dead for most of the season but if
they're gonna bring him back i think
it's going to be around the middle of
the series i think the point of keeping
him dead for now is showing the rise of
Sansa they don't want him to steal any
of her thunder because she got drug
through the mud all through season five
now season six is all about badass [ __ ]
Sansa and if Jon Snow were to come back
in the first episode nobody would be
paying attention to Sansa and I think
especially just seeing how much
his trailer focuses on her they want you
to focus on her for the first couple of
episodes next question Joshua asks now
that we know Sansa is probably going to
get an army do you think that the
northern Lords who join her will
proclaim her queen in the north yeah I
definitely think it's going to be
another version of Rob stark king of the
north as for whether they literally call
her Queen in the North like someone says
that out loud remains to be seen they
might gave that to Cersei like during
the War of the five kings when people
were talking about the king in the north
usually it was Lannister characters
usually was the small council talking
about look at this Robb Stark who's
proclaimed himself king in the north
however they choose to express it that's
definitely the imagery they're going for
with Sansa though thank you so much for
so many questions these are always a ton
of fun to do there's going to be a bunch
of more EPK that they'll be dropping
just because the season so close we
still have a couple weeks to go but just
remember big theme of the trailer is
misdirection do not be surprised if they
wave shiny in your face so that you're
not paying attention when big WTF comes
along later a giveaway time
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner a key husan you win a twenty
dollar amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so i can get your contact
details that's just on the about page
there's a whole bunch of big stuff
happening later tonight so be sure to
check my Twitter and Facebook for
updates such as facebook.com / emergency
awesome their links in the description
for all that stuff while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here to watch the trailer again and you
can click here to watch the big Suicide
Squad trailer video I just did thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you